dans la lutte au cancer une des
difficultés est de déceler les cellules
tumorales de façon précoce avant qu'elle
est eu le temps de causer des dommages à
l'organisme une chercheuse française a
trouvé à procéder détection unique au
monde un échantillon de sang dans ces
quelques millilitres une intruse une
cellule cancéreuse
une seule et il faut la trouver patricia
paterlini bréchot est une sommité
mondiale depuis 25 ans
son objectif est limpide comme de l'eau
le but c'est de transformer le cancer
d'une maladie fréquemment mortel à une
maladie curable traquer la cellule
trouver l'organe d'où elle provient pour
nicolas tétrault
il faut surtout y parvenir des années
avant l'apparition des premiers
symptômes
imaginez un rendez vous chez le médecin
au reprise de ça un peu une tendace de
routine finalement et on va pouvoir
dépister si en un cancer en phase
précoce cette idée on y rêve depuis 100
ans
or nous sommes peut-être sur le point
d'y arriver
[Musique]
quand on détecte un camp certes il est
souvent trop tard
la tumeur est bien implanté pourtant des
années avant le diagnostic le sample
trahir la présence d'une tumeur en
devenir
alors pourquoi c'est difficile parce que
ces cellules sont extrêmement rares
elles sont très fragiles elles se
cachent et elle ses métamorphoses
donc on a vraiment un but qui est
difficile quand la cellule cancéreuse se
détache de la tumeur elle se mélange à
100 millions de globules blancs et 50
milliards de globules rouges
aussi bien dire une goutte dans l'océan
[Musique]
qu'ils travaillent en europe ou au
québec ces chercheurs ne craignent pas
le défi chacun se prend sa façon
tout part de la tumeur d'un côté on
s'intéresse à la cellule cancéreuse qui
s'en détachent et de l'autre on étudie
les fragments d'adr et des rites à la
tumeur lorsque les cellules tumorales
vont mourir y voir une destruction en
quelque sorte de l'adn donc le matériel
génétique relâché vous nous donner
beaucoup d'informations sur la sur
l'origine de la tumeur
patricia paterlini bréchot elle se
concentre plutôt sur la cellule entière
et pour la distinguer du lot elle
dispose d'un 10
[Musique]
donc nous on utilise la taille parce que
les cellules tumorales sont plus grandes
que les cellules sanguines
ça c'est ultra démontré en exploitant
ces indices morphologiques et l'a trouvé
un procédé de détection unique au monde
il s'est tu
[Musique]
il était est une méthode qui permet
d'isoler les cellules tumorales qui
circulent dans le son avec la plus forte
sensibilité connu parce qu'on arrive à
détecter une cellule dans dix mille
litres de sang dans plus de 95 % des cas
même une fois la cellule détecter la
partie n'est pas gagnée
c'est très variable des cancers à cancer
on sait qu'on peut remonter des quelques
années mais on a besoin de beaucoup plus
d'études pour le savoir dans certains
cancers
quelle est la précocité du test et aussi
le défi en fait de remonter aux cancers
d'origine
est ce qu'on est capable d'associer hors
de tout doute le cancer d'origine est
vraiment laid investiguer cet endroit là
ce qu'on comprend une chose difficile
cancer l'on suit faut agir ce qu'on sera
là si on est capable de savoir hors de
tout doute la provenance
évidemment le traitement va être utilisé
pour tout le monde certaines tumeurs ne
relâchent aucune cellule ni fragments
mais 60 % des cancers pourront quand
même être détectée à temps
même lorsqu on parviendra lé décelé il
faudra se poser une question faut-il ou
non intervenir
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que certains
types de cancers qui sont mieux laisser
tranquille par exemple certains cancers
qui vont évoluer très lentement dans ta
on y rêve depuis 100 ans
il reste encore quelques pas à franchir
pour y arriver
mais pour elle le but est atteint
si on arrive à la détecter avant que la
maladie fasse des dégâts elle va devenir
curable comme le diabète comprend au
tout début
c'est une révolution
[Musique]